好,我们今天来做个学员访谈
今天访谈的陈陈,她说她以前是稳定在股市输钱的玩家
那跟我学了完全零主观的台子期交易策略之后
就是她说她单纯靠我的教她的策略
这个月11月已经赚到了一百一十几万
然后我们就来稍微访谈她一下
那我以前也没有打给她过,我也不认识她
所以就
反正我们就访谈她这样子
喂喂
喂
喂,晨晨
嗨嗨嗨嗨
好,那我今天稍微访谈你一下
因为
这个
你算是进步蛮多嘛
然后
我也不太知道你的故事
所以今天来问你一下
这样
然后
晨晨跟我今天是第一次同话
然后以前也没有见过面
就是以前不认识
就是
单纯是因为跟我学台子期才认识的
这样
好,那你稍微
那你稍微
呃,讲一下你以前的工作啊
或者是一些
啊,随便啦
随便自我介绍
好,反正你就是唱所欲
你想讲什么,讲什么
呵呵呵呵
然后稍微讲一下
就是我本身
大学是文族毕业的
就是文族毕业的
那基本上
那一般毕业其实对一些财经的东西都是明清楚
他自己是后来退伍后找到了工作
然后就是保险业务
然后后来保险我做的时候发现
不是说想要
所以我就要去考一些金融证照
然后就金融证照
考到之后才有那个资格进去银行嘛
所以后来就考到了之后
就有进去银行工作过一段时间了
是银行里面跟管钱有关的
金融财务有关的工作是吗
就是柜台
好,银行柜台
那会用到一些经济学金融这些知识吗
不太会
可是在考证照的时候会
所以你是有总体经济学的知识背景
对,因为考证照他都会有要求这些东西
然后进去银行的基本门槛也是要有一些证照
OK,这个应该
你觉得对股市这个应该还是很有帮助吧
我觉得有耶
因为我原本是想要做银砖
所以银砖需要的证照我也去考虑
就是一些衍生性金融商品啊
然后就基金类的一些东西的证照
都有考到
然后
原本也差点去做那个证券验眼
但是我一直证券的那个证照一直考不到
不知道为什么
蛤
其他的都对我来说都OK
可是我就不晓得为什么证券的
就是考了三次
后来就放弃了
好
没有
我上个月
读了一天去考的那个就是
就是
你刚说的那个正常
哈哈哈
基本的
我觉得很奇怪
我考试的那个
考题刚好都很怪
他都出那个民国七十几年
问你发生了什么事情
那考试就很白痴啊
他都考很智障的事
他
我印象超深刻
他考什么
什么盖一个旗交所
是要十亿二十亿还是四十亿
我想说
我又没有要盖交易所
到底为什么要问我
要多少亿
其实那时候超习惯
就是完全就是集图
或者是那个书里面完全没有讲的东西
那个考试本来就是这样
对
你觉得自己的运气有多差
因为其他的基因的征照对我来说
都没有很难
就觉得还OK
对
所以就是
证券就超怪
好
OK
那我后来就没有去券商嘛
然后
之后就转做
啊
因为刚好遇到房市
很热
嗯
房市在很热霧
然后就有朋友
就搞好自己当店长了
就跟我一起
找我去
幫他
嗯
就可能当他的副手
是房仲吗
还是什么
对对对对
它是房仲
OKOK
所以
你以前读
好
反正是文主
但是是跟金融财经有关的科系
是吗
不是没有关系
哦没有关系
好
没关系
好没关系
反正就是
以前不太擅长数学这样
但是
有学过金融
然后当过银行的柜台跟房仲
但是有金融的经济学知识
你知道吗
因为其实有经济学知识
你会比较看得懂
在学的那些东西是什么吗
哦对啊
对啊
对对
好
那
呃
你的交易
从以前到现在的经验的转变
也跟大家分享一下
以前同志经历
可能就是
跟很多人一样
就是
台股嘛
先从台股开始买
然后可能也是
就是听大家在讲啊
新闻在报啊
就是跟着买
他通常跟着买就是被张韭菜啦
后来也发现这件事情
然后
就会自己去看一些新闻嘛
就去多了解说
欸现在的趋势是什么
这些最近还流行什么
才慢慢的开始有
比别人找一步进场的机会
等到后来发现
台股好像
不像美股那样子
会受整个经济的影响吧
就是比如说美股可能就说
哎
财报出来啊
可能就会大涨啊
什么的
或是消息片一出来
可能那个
就会跟着波动
台股好像都还好
所以后来又去转做美股
就开那个美国的券商
然后去交易美股
然后还有特别股
特别股
我觉得算是蛮有趣的产品
也是从
赞银行的时候
才认识到这个东西
就很像
债券
他也是会配息
有些会计配息
有些是年配息
这样子
还有月配息
所以大家就是
特别股
我有做过的那些
特别股是有
赚到钱的
然后后来就
认识了马克扬之后
才开始做期货
大概这样子
OK
所以
其实
就是在跟我学台子期之前
你的生涯累积的交易
或者是投资
其实是有赚到钱的
算有赚到
但赚的速度
没有现在那么快
OKOK
大概会是一年几%
一年吧
以前
最好的话
大概是
一期前到一前
后这一年
如果是生涯
除以生涯
生涯除以生涯
大概
生涯可能才
生涯很少
大概才
可能才
10%
如果算上
最高的
那其实也还不错
如果是一年的话
如果一年的话
最高是有半倍
OKOK
好
那
诶
那你
因为
就是
你11月
目前
是
赢了
112万
是
全部都是打
我
交的
就是
完全零主观的
太子期策略吗
还是
也有打一些
在其他书上看到
或是什么
就是
几乎都是
馬克弘的策略
所以
我觉得
很重要就是
不要有
任何的
主观意识
OK
没有
用自己的主观意识
在尝试的时候
基本上都是赔钱
OK
很重要
就是
基本上
你就是
完全照策略
打
对
照策略
然后
我给自己
就是
因为我有时候
在
交易完
赚钱的策略
之后
我会继续看
就是
软件开车
就继续看
但有时候
会手痒
会想要去瞎盖
啊
基本上
那时候
操作的
都是
亏钱的
所以
后来
就是
有
赚到钱之后
我就
直接把
系统全关掉
OK
我没有解释
就是
照着数学打
会赚钱
然后赚到钱之后
就会想说
那就
赌运气赌一下
然后可能
就会
有输一点
回去
对
所以后来
有赚到之后
我就直接关了
剩下的
给其他人赚吧
我不要
那感觉
对啊
其实这样真的是
比较正确
就是
全部的
每一个动作
每一个action
都是有数学根据的
然后没有数学根据的
动作就完全不要打
然后完全
就是
最理想的话
完全
像是AI一样在执行
就是不要有任何人类的想法
就是
完全
完全使用数学跟科学来打
其实不管是poker啊
不管是交易啊
或者是
其实大部分的事情
真的都是这样
就是
有太多人类的情绪跟想法
一定会输给
就是
完全照着数学
像是AI一样
执行的人
对
没错
真的
后来真的认识到
你知道才了解到
这个事情
真的非常重要
对对对
因为其实
那种什么
判断超级强的人
他们其实
其实就是他们的判断
强到跟AI差不多
只是他讲不出原因而已
哈哈
哈哈哈
他老运算很快
你知道
不知道怎么把它
做
呃
不一定是运算很快
因为像是
这个
围棋啊
或者是
股票啊
其实有时候
他们会说那是一个盘感
但是
事实上
就是
如果是用
这个
分析啊
就是
来说的话
他们的做法
其实是跟AI非常接近
然后所以是非常厉害
这样
对
我说在围棋上
好
那
诶
你大概
你今
这个月
赚112万
那你
大概
估计一下
你这个月
总共看盘时间
大概是多少
你
大概平均一天
要花多久
看盘
我
从
之前
是
几乎
就是
一开盘
就盯着
嗯
然后
我夜盘
也都盯着
基本上
第一个月
我几乎
没有在睡觉
然后开盘的时间
我都
醒着
ok ok
一直想去
去了解那个持续的道理
就没有
真的
用处
可能有办法
赚到钱吧
一开始就是
从一口小台
开始吸
就是有
讯号出来
我就跟他们做
ok
是学习阶段的时候吗
是学习阶段的时候
花了很多时间
去
收令
其实收令
也蛮重要的
对对对
后来就
发现到说
其实不需要
花那么长的时间
就是
熟悉之后
我们就锁定个时间
像我这个月开始
就是
比如说早上
大概
给自己的时间
一个小时
两个小时
就看上天
有没有事情
如果没事
我可能就
11点前
一定要结束
不管也没有
或者是
我都要关掉
对
就设定一段时间
然后像
夜盘也是
就是大概
如果有
有策略要执行的话
那天如果有策略要执行的话
就是
就是晚点睡
嗯嗯嗯
如果没有的话
我们就
看一下
就是
基本的策略
有没有办法
实施
如果没有
那就
12点前
我希望
可以睡就好
ok ok
我希望
可以再正常
诶你现在是
也是
就是打
早上
9点到
10点
然后最多到
10点多的那个
策略嘛
然后加上
晚上
只打
重大数据公布
看了差不多
所以
晚上
大概一个月
需要看个五次
之类的
然后看个一个小时
这样
是吗
对对
因为我有在
玫瑰拍摄
可以看
ok ok
缠早那个数据
再决定要不要
进场
ok ok
所以
统整来说的话就是
呃
以你现在
就是我们
打的策略组合
应该是
早上只需要看
9点到10点
最多10点出头
然后晚上的话
是一个月
大概看五次
然后都是一个小时之内
可以结束
其实
其实10几分钟之内
就一定可以结束啦
因为就是打
那个重大数据公布的
接下来那
三五分钟而已
对啊
就是
一下子而已
不需要再画
几天在电脑前面
对对
其实三五分钟
都是久了啦
这个那个重大数据公布
根本就是一瞬间
刷刷
几秒钟就结束了
好
诶
那你现在
就
诶
你主要工作
是
防众吗
呃
算
兼职吧
现在
转成兼职了
诶
以前是
需要
每天要报告
需要开会
哦
对啊
现在是
兼职的话
就是
不需要每天去
哦
OK
诶
那所以主要就是
就是
赚
当充这样
市货当充
对啊
OK
好
所以
诶
我稍微整理一下
就是
啊
你以前是
就是
读
跟文
文
文类科有关的
然后
就是
其实
学这些策略
也不需要什么
很高深的数学
就是
真
我觉得真的很重要的
就是像你说的
就是
不要太有人类的想法
对对对
就是完全照着
数学来做
因为很多人会输钱就是
太有人类的想法
对
或者是输了
不愿意
从水
对对对对对
对
我
这一次的那个
群艺的冬季讲座也是
主要是讲这个
讲这个话题
好
等你
等你影片收开
对啊
应该过了过一两天
摄影大哥
就会弄好
OK
好
那大概是
是这样
诶
你有什么
其他想分享的吗
嗯
就是
未来的运劲的话
大概希望可以跟马克一样一样吧
就是可以实现那个
商务车
车厢的自由
呵呵呵呵
没有
诶
你这个月已经
已经赢我了
我这个月
目前才
赚四十几万
然后你已经
一百亿四十几
哈哈哈
嗯
时间应该没有那么长吧
有其实差不多啊
我觉得主要是因为我被退单了三次啊
如果没有被退单应该是跟你差不多的数字
你也被退
你也被退单
对不对
对啊
我也是啊
诶
你是CPI跟FED都有被退单吗
还是被退一次
同样的是
因为
它说是
超过五口
要用範圍試駕嘛,就一樣的Bug格。
哦,對啊,那個工程師真的很天兵耶,就把最高100口改成最高5口。
傻眼。
對啊,所以如果那個再加上去,你這個月可能會賺到150萬以上。
有可能,那個真的會很多。
真的差很多。
好,好,那反正就是,基本上你就是從這個保險業務啊,銀行櫃檯的工作到現在,可以單純靠領主觀的胎子旗當充,一個月賺超過100萬。
大概是這樣的故事,對吧?
好,那就這樣啦,謝謝,掰掰。
掰掰。